la maman du petit laurent retournent au
travail en janvier malgré de très
nombreuses démarches il semble
impossible de lui trouver un milieu de
garde
j'ai fait environ 120 appels dans
différents milieux
donc puisque c'est sans compter toutes
les messages facebook que j'ai envoyée
en est que j'ai contactés par courriel
elle n'est pas seule dans cette
situation non seulement sur les réseaux
sociaux mais aussi à l'alliance des
intervenantes en milieu familial de
l'estrie les appels à l'aide sont
nombreux
je reçois des appels de parents à chaque
semaine puis je souhaite les fermetures
de milieu de gamme à chaque semaine
aussi selon elle si les responsables
désertent la profession c'est que les
conditions sont trop exigeante parce que
le ministre ressort toujours les
règlements et toujours plus plus plus
d'exigences les salaires est toujours la
main mais pas de bonification des
conditions de travail
il n'y a pas de reconnaissance de la
profession devant l'impasse mylène
tremblay a contacté les élus de la
région
elle a trouvé une oreille attentive chez
le député solidaire de sherbrooke
j'en reçois très souvent des messages de
parent je dirais désespéré la somme des
pressions pour retourner au travail
parfois ils ont déjà prolongé de
quelques mois leurs congés en
poursuivant leurs recherches et ne
trouvent toujours pas donc c'est quand
même assez fait quand même assez
problématique de voir que bon des femmes
principalement sont pas en mesure de
retourner sur le marché du travail
à la suggestion de kristine labrie la
nouvelle maman a poussé ses démarches
plus loin j'ai crié au ministère de la
famille j'ai pas eu de retour de leur
part mais ministre est bien au fait de
la situation si tout se passe bien et
que 100% des projets vont de l'avant
dans les délais prescrits
il y aura plus de 500 places près de 600
en fait seront disponibles pour les
parents de l'estrie d'ici 2022 pour
régler le problème le ministre sic il
faudra mettre en place un plan d'action
pour retenir la main d'oeuvre et attirer
des jeunes dans la profession
si on est capable de trouver des
éducatrices en milieu familial dans la
communauté qui sont prêtes à se lancer
dans cette aventure là des places
subventionnées y en a plus de 500
actuellement qui sont disponibles qui
peuvent être octroyées dans les
prochaines semaines mais faut que des
gens lèvent la main sur ces classes des
nouvelles peu encourageantes pour mylène
tremblay et son petit laurent
ici fait ni la chance packet radio
canada sherbrooke